Auf dem planeten zäher es wurde ein mysteriöses quadrat entdeckt und das ausgerechnet im orca tor krater
der mit dem hellsten fleck auf dem planeten haben uns aliens ihre spuren hinterlassen die wir nur mit
hochentwickelter technologie einer weit entwickelten zivilisation entdecken können ein nicht unwahrscheinliches szenario klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
In 2001 odyssee im weltraum nahm außerirdische genauso kontakt zur menschheit auf nur da war das mysteriöse objekt auf dem
mond kann es also sein dass eine hoch entwickelte
zivilisation so kontakt zu uns auf nimmt die umstände dabei sind schon ein wenig verrückt und wenn man sich diese
filmvorlage als orientierung nimmt spricht vieles dafür aber es könnte eben auch nur ein wunschgedanke
sein und fantasie die mit uns durch geht aber der reihe nach entdeckt wurde series
1801 aber erst vor wenigen jahren 2006 wurde er mit seinem durchmesser von rund 900 kilometern in die gruppe der zwergplaneten
eingeordnet ein jahr später am 27 september
2007 wurde die sonde dawn führt er es geschickt erst acht jahre später erreichte sie cs am 6 märz
2015 seitdem schießen
spektakuläre bilder von cs und hat den zwergplaneten inzwischen komplett kartografiert bereits am 13 januar sendete die sonne ein
rätselhaftes bild an die erde sie hatte einen extrem hellen weißen fleck entdeckt der sofort die aufmerksamkeit
der wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen auf sich zog fast ein jahr später konnte das rätsel der flecken im krater
gelöst werden aber die lösung macht es nicht weniger mysteriös zum einen stellte sich heraus dass es mehrere flecken waren
und diese licht aussenden beziehungsweise sonnenlicht reflektieren was das spektrum von
mineralsalzen wiedergab genauer hydra visierte
magnesium sulfat aber noch spannender war ein anderes phänomen in krater schwebt ein dünner nehme das forschungsteam
schließt auf verdampfendes wasser perfekt also für eine mission mit menschen zu dem zwergplaneten doch dann gab es eine weitere
sensation die nasa hat die mission inzwischen mehrfach verlängert und schwenkte die sonde inzwischen auf eine elliptische umlaufbahn ein vorteil
ich kann jetzt viel dichter an series heranfliegen und dabei entdeckte sie etwas
ziemlich verrücktes am 22 märz
2016 überflug dorn den zwergplaneten in nur 385 kilometern und entdeckte in einem hellen flecken dem vinalia
fakultät eine quadratische struktur einerseits etwas das auch durch zufälle in der natur gebildet werden könnte aber andererseits eine ziemlich
mathematische struktur es wäre ein symbol das genauso wahrscheinlich
außerirdische zum beginn einer
kommunikation verwenden würden und jetzt gibt es noch bessere bilder die die sache nicht besser machen denn zum einen ist das quadrat nicht perfekt
quadratisch eine ecke fehlt quasi aber beim genaueren hinsehen sieht man ein zweites quadrat in quadrath
etwas dunkler und das ist ziemlich perfekt es bleibt also spannend und wenn der irgendwann in der lage sind das quadrat näher zu untersuchen
dann könnte es vielleicht das tor in eine andere welt sein oder
eine große enttäuschung
also wenn er kein video dazu zum beispiel und zu anderen themen verpassen wollt auch extra videos spezielle
livestreams und so weiter dann werdet mitglied die auf dem kanal und nehmt noch ein paar
privilegien mit außerdem unterstützt er uns mit einem kleinen betrag
einfach mit wild werden also direkt hier unter dem video draufklicken und vielen vielen dank an alle die das schon gemacht haben wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endlich bei whatsapp dann umgeht denn die etwas
unzuverlässiger aber ob sie auf youtube und er verpasst kann video einfach hier draufklicken
und hier da geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken aliens der erste kontakt bis dann
bleibt dran